okay good morning
all right um this is a bit where I
secretly checked my mics are still
working by saying a name things at you
that seems to be working I can hear
myself raise your hand if you can hear
me
raise your hand if you hate speakers we
make you raise your hand You're Gonna
Love Me Right good morning it is an
absolute privilege and a surprise to be
a security person doing a keynote at a
developer conference like can I get a
whoo for like the brave
Brave New terrifying future we're all in
so hooray yay
um this talk is a really great
opportunity for me it's
um this type of talk isn't I'm not here
to show you lines and code and go hey
here's some syntax and you should love
it
I'm here to share a little bit of an
adventure I've been on because I've been
lots of things a software developer a
security person all sorts of things
um and even in my 20 plus years
of doing this
so much has changed raise your hand if
you've been doing this more than five
years
more than 10.
more than 20. arm doesn't work anymore
it's sore don't make me put it down all
right so this is me
um I am a fairly average 38 year old I
do code stuff I write terrible code a
lot
um I write some average code when
there's good peer review on it
but I am unusual in that I'm a bit of a
security Optimist which is about the
most dissonance you're going to get in
this conference
I am genuinely excited about the future
of technology
raise your hand if you're excited about
the technology we are building today and
not what you're paid to do but the other
stuff the stuff over there great awesome
we're not quite building The Fifth
Element and you know nobody aspires to
be that but
we are building some pretty cool stuff
now ignore the Tesla nonsense that gets
launched
but even just look at robots I love
robots
um I did my thesis is was in artificial
intelligence and Robotics before that
was actually a career path and so I look
at what Boston Dynamics are doing and
I'm like this is pretty cool also
terrifying because spot the dog when I
was a kid was small and yellow and kept
getting lost somewhere and not coming
home for dinner but this spot I don't
think is going to get lost and in fact
it was going to probably make sure
nobody is late for dinner
I love robot doctors I love the fact
that we are taking people to space even
if I'm kind of convinced it's a bit of a
shadow Enterprise in mining but we'll
just leave that to the side
I love the fact that the Sci-Fi future
that I read about and I watched when I
was growing up is being built and not
just is it being built but it could be
being built by us by people just like us
it's not some kind of has to sit in a
funny place that invents it it's
literally the software engineers in this
room and Beyond
and that's cool
but it's also a little bit scary because
with that great power comes great
responsibility if you believe the
cliches and it really does because with
every amazing robot army dog thing we
have
we have to then make sure this thing
doesn't go wrong and that we don't use
it to share government secrets or
something I don't know what would you
possibly do with a robot dog if you
hacked it who knows
so in this talk I'm going to do three
things
I decided that if I was going to
understand how we secure this amazing
future
I was going to take a look at the code
I'd written in the past and take a look
at how that had changed and how that had
impacted the security of what it is now
so I picked three things that I have
been involved in building and taking a
look at those
then I'm going to share with us some of
the changes that we're going to have to
face as Engineers this is not about SQL
injection the future of security looks
very different to what you've been
taught so far
and then at the end and spoilers
foreshadowing there's going to be a QR
code and it's not a rickroll
because I'm trying to do something I
want to give all of you a gift of extra
work to do which I know is your favorite
sort of conference swag
so
um watch for that at the end but let's
have a little bit of an adventure
through space and time while I share
what I have worked on now I'm not here
to show off that these are cool things I
thought they were cool you're going to
have your own Adventures you'll have
your own examples of systems you've
worked on that would be completely
different now
but it helps tell the story
so this is me this is me in a timeline I
started out as a software developer age
16 entirely by accident I got made
homeless a little bit suddenly somebody
got very sick and in my hometown which
is famous for two things teenage
pregnancy and car theft there was two
job options available I could go and
work for somewhere like a factory or you
know McDonald's somewhere in kind of
it would pay the bills but it wasn't
particularly glamorous
or EDS happened to have a big office in
my hometown and EDS doesn't really exist
anymore it was acquired by HP but they
did software development for the Inland
Revenue in the UK and so at the age of
16 I took on the brave new future as a
COBOL developer
this was in the year 2000 so you can see
how far from the future I really
actually was now from there I've been on
an amazing invention I've been
incredibly lucky and I've also been
really silly at times and just taken
chances that I didn't know what was
going to happen but that's fine too I've
done Ai and Robotics
before that was a job option at
University having spent a lot of money
coming out with a degree nobody
understood
I worked at CERN for the LHC and we're
going to talk a bit about that I've done
counterterrorism and counterpedophilia
and I have done penetration testing and
red teaming and hacking and now I live
in a strange world where I help very
fast-paced software development teams
all around the world figure out how to
do security for whatever they're
building so if you think about it this
way I've become that weird little pencil
note on a recipe so I don't know if any
of you have recipe books at home it's
still a thing I'm told but you look at
that recipe that's been passed down from
your nan or whoever and somewhere
there's a pencil note that scribbled out
something and said do not do this it
will suck
and nobody knows where that pencil note
came from nobody knows who wrote it or
when but you know if you follow that
tiny instruction then the cake is going
to be better at the end and that's what
Security is to me I'm trying to make a
lot of cakes taste a little bit better
and be forgotten
so let's get into it
the first thing about securing the
future has to be internet of things and
I started off in Internet of things at
Sun
internet of things back in 2005 was not
what we're used to now how many raise
your hand if you have an Internet of
Things device on you today it's probably
a smart watch to be honest
any of you got the smart socks I'm
curious to know who buys those
no okay all right I still I'm still
going to keep trying
um iot back then and back for me was
about physics my job was to monitor
background radiation at the LHC so the
Large Hadron Collider which is a giant
particle accelerator underneath
Switzerland and underneath the French
border and decide that a radiation
threshold had been met and decide to do
some stuff okay good just to be clear
for anyone who's not a physics nerd I
was not a physics nerd I applied for a
job because it was in Switzerland
um but hey ho doing stuff means that
you've got lots and lots of particles
whizzing around really really really
really fast and if you happen to say aim
them at a human bad things will happen
so instead of letting bad things happen
if the radiation escapes from where it's
supposed to be you send it to the place
labeled dump which is essentially a
giant concrete chamber underneath the
ground that has been built specifically
to withstand radiation so I was 23 no
pressure
um
there was me on this project me and one
senior Hardware engineer from the
Netherlands
that's what internet of things look like
back then it was custom built electronic
devices and firmware
that at the time were being mostly coded
in things like C plus
in terms of the application layer there
was talk of real-time Java there was
very Furious talk of real-time Java and
there had been since 1996
it didn't happen
but this is our lives we had a small
Porter cabin on a site in Geneva we
built devices we wrote software and then
we threshold tested it with absolutely
no fancy tools at all and then we buried
it under the ground and hoped the
radiation thing worked out
fantastic now thankfully internet of
things now isn't all about large deadly
doses of radiation that's that's good
fantastic how many of you write software
that's to do with radiation anyone
super fun you could go do that if you
wanted
um the solution now though is very
different right all right perhaps not
for particle accelerators but iot is
everywhere it's everywhere to the point
that this morning literally reading my
news this morning President Biden in the
U.S has declared that the cyber security
Center is going to create a voluntary
standard for the security of iot things
now the key word being voluntary here so
we'll see how that goes but
it's a sign of the times there is so
much iot now there are so many different
devices and ways it's impacting our
lives that a nation-state that is
considered one of the most powerful on
Earth has decided yeah we might want to
think about yeah some rules or something
how many of you do any iot development
for fun or profit I know at least one of
you does I spoke to him over the last
two days you should totally talk to the
dude who does irrigation systems for a
living it's fascinating stuff
now if you wanted to do it you can go to
AWS you can download a whole range of
off-the-shelf sdks and get going you can
buy commodity Hardware from General
stores you can go to a store and buy an
Arduino kit if you want to just get
going it doesn't take a lot of expense
it doesn't take a lot of time and this
is a great thing and also as a security
person it's absolutely terrifying
because this means that every single
person who wants to can build a little
device that can do something measure
something change something in our world
and then leave them there and they're
everywhere and
as a security person who's also a
developer I find myself torn into at the
concept I'm like yes this is exciting
but also why
so every element from our Gardens
onwards is connected to Bluetooth now
every time you do an iot security thing
you should always go and look at
AliExpress so just for you know if you
want Fun and Profit I wanted to see if I
was writing radiation monitoring
software today would I even need to
bother do they already create commodity
hardware for managing radiation and then
connecting it to your phone well of
course they do so it only has a one star
or star review so I'm not commercially
involved in this in any way but
um
everything you can imagine that would be
an iot device right now is not just
being made by Engineers who are sat in
this room who care about professional
development who are trying to be great
high quality Engineers it is being built
in often cases for the lowest possible
cost in locations all around the world
and sold online to people who just want
to solve a problem
and that to me is exciting but
terrifying because
where's the responsibility in this how
do we know that this works how do we
know where the data is going
the OAS top 10 isn't built to protect
you from an iot geiger counter
it's not in the threat model
an iot applications are everywhere right
from health
so our smart watches our scales our
Medical Systems in our hospitals so when
we see ransomware attacks we see where
this goes wrong and people get hurt
it's also in our retail with the
increasing rise in being able to shop
without you know talking to a human
being because who wants to do that
anymore
we have it everywhere and we will see
more of it and we will see more of it to
an extent that we will forget that
they're computers
and from a security point of view that's
really hard when you forget something is
software
when you forget that it is the lines of
logic that you're used to creating
then security becomes very difficult for
you to focus on
because well you're just Watering your
garden you're just telling the time of
measuring your heart rate
you're not thinking about the thousands
and thousands of lines of code and the
connectivity that is around you all the
time to make that work
the next thing I decided to try and do
because you know being ahead of my time
and not paid for it was super fun
was I got really into natural language
processing and this was my happy place
in 2005.
in 2005 I decided I was going to write
an application that would help me learn
French this was well before Duolingo was
a thing
the idea was I wanted to talk to
somebody in French and I wanted them to
talk back to me in French and I wanted
them to tell me that my French was not
terrible or at least give me pointers in
the right direction what I'm saying is I
really wanted to have a friend and I was
really not good at that so instead I
wrote code has anyone done that before
it's like I don't have a friend right
now I'll just build something it's all
right I don't judge you're amongst
friends
um so that's what I did I built software
it was
it was a thing it was 30 000 lines of
java now if you're going to write
natural language processing tools right
now you're not going to choose geography
language but in 2005 that was really the
strongest language we had for this now
Python and pearl were still a thing but
we'll come back to Pearl later and why
that's never a good idea
but there were no existing libraries and
Frameworks even in Academia these were
largely theoretical
the tests and things were being done
with NLP were the foundations of what
would later pass Turing tests but it was
experimental
what we had to do was we read really fun
books like this one it's very expensive
don't go buy it find it in a library but
it was essentially statistical modeling
of language and then turning into the
biggest if statement you have ever
considered in your entire life if you
looked at the 30 000 lines of code I'd
say 70 of it was nested IFS
and that was the reality of AI at that
point
that there was a fancy name for it it
wasn't called giant if statement AI
uh but that's what it was and it worked
it took a conversation and it gave back
some comments and feedback and it gave
me a friend to learn French from I
didn't get very far with it because you
know after writing 30 000 lines of
nested if statements I decided going out
and getting some sunshine was a good
idea
but there was no cloud computing it was
all running locally the interfaces as
you can imagine in 2005 were as glorious
as they were in the the ASP space at
that time let alone the Java Swing
monstrosities we were building
so what's changed how many of you
writing AI or machine Learning Systems
now any of you been playing with it
you should totally have a play if you
haven't it's an amazing space now
now I decided a few weeks ago I have an
innovation day at my company and I was
like right screw this I'm going to see
if I can rebuild what I built
you know a long time ago revisit my
youth do the things that you do when you
were young
and I was delighted not only were the
one or two Frameworks there were dozens
of Frameworks available I could
literally off the shelf pull a framework
in Python
and off I went there were pre-compiled
corpuses not just in English but in
multiple languages not just big corpuses
so corpses being giant collections of
words that have been annotated in a way
so that you can process the meaning of
language
but there were small versions suitable
for mobile great wonderful I didn't need
to do anything
in fact I didn't my code which was
previously 30 000 lines of java boiled
down to two slides worth of code
now part of me was delighted hooray
exciting future I can now build the
friend that I've always wanted
but
then part of me was like well hang on a
second I know how much complexity was
under the hood when I built this the
first time and if any of you have ever
built networking connection code so
you've had to set up the ports and the
connections you will know this when you
first wrote it and you had to handle the
connections and you had to make sure
everything was synchronous and
everything worked and now we don't now
we have one line in our framework that
sets it up for us
now does this mean we don't have to do
security anymore because the framework
is there and it's easy
no it just changes the way we have to
think about security because we're not
controlling any of this anymore
we've got a big Corpus of data that we
can use that somebody else built I'm
sure that's fine right you just use
software from other people off the
internet all the time that's perfectly
fine
that was the the other part of it this
little bit here for anyone who cares um
I don't do live demos because nobody
actually really enjoys them that much
this looks for certain parts of speech I
was particularly interested in pulling
out keyword phrases from some large
texts so I wanted to know if I was going
to create a glossary of text could I do
that turns out I could I could just
decide which parts of phrases I wanted
and the relations they should have to
each other and I could just dump them
all out fantastic now in a way the
problem was solved and I felt a bit sad
because security and and coding had
become too easy
this was it
what had been 30 000 lines of painful
code is now this in fact it gets worse
because then I was like well you know
I'm not really excited by this python
now because well somebody did the hard
bit so I went online and found out that
not only is there a Gartner quadrant for
this but you can now have a low code and
no code interface to build your own
artificial intelligent chatbot
fantastic we've all been replaced
so the future is bright the future is no
code how any of you embracing no code in
your world right now or you've got some
of it going on
yeah does anyone feel a bit weird about
going down the no code route it's like
cheating
well when we get to this level of extra
abstraction from what we're trying to do
as a security person I really start
getting a bit nervous
because it's wonderful that I can create
my best friend with no code
but
what's actually going on under there how
do you understand the risks in a system
that you cannot see the pathways through
that you cannot can't understand the
decisions that are being made where you
can't understand the data that is being
used to feed it to make those decisions
now that got me thinking and I'm going
to come back to what it got me thinking
about
I decided after I was playing with my
natural language things and that was not
making me happy anymore
that I would revisit the last of these
projects now back in 2007 I was employed
by gchq and one of the things I was
involved with was counterterrorism and
reducing online harm to children
now I'm not here to talk about
intelligence Services literally they put
me in prison if I do that but they don't
mind if I talk about nerdy things so
that's okay
my job
was to map the relationships between
individuals in online social communities
identify aliases and fake accounts and
identify those with power and influence
in networks now if any of you have
actually been on the internet in the
last two weeks
you might notice even in 2007 we had
exactly the same problems as we have now
with fake accounts disinformation power
Brokers and aliases sock bookbicts the
whole thing has been going a very long
time so if anyone turns around tells you
this is a new problem on the internet
they're young
there's a few of us who've been around a
while that know this is not a new
problem this is a human problem and for
as long as it's been humans humans have
pretended to be other humans to
essentially cause trouble
now how many of you old enough to know
or have used a forum like this
oh hi old people
my people yeah this is the bulletin now
V bulletin was the thing it was the
Forum software the most popular form of
software on the internet between 2000
and 2007 when it was the first acquired
it eventually died out and stopped
having a active development in 2012. but
at this point in time whether you were a
gamer or doing nasty things on the
internet you probably set up your
communities using software that looked a
lot like this
and you know it did the job it was PHP
it was not the most glamorous PHP in
fact there's a really well
publicized incident that happened with
uh V Bolton it's one of the reasons it
became less popular where you could
there was a vulnerability to let you get
the password to the admin account of the
V bulletin server with no technical
ability so that led to some problems
that you might imagine in control of the
communities but my job was to take
forums like this and jabber and the tail
end of icq and all of those messaging
systems we wish had died
and turn them into the connections
between humans
now how did that work back then
it involved a lot of Pearl and regex and
I I have still got my little O'Reilly
regex tiny little handbook which is so
well thumbed that the pages are now
decrepit and you probably wouldn't want
to touch it from a hygiene perspective
but
my job was to take really mangled data
that wasn't designed to be mapped or
graphed or to be de-ambiguated and turn
it into nice things those nice things
being used to identify the people who
were causing harm to others so from my
point of view it was a very important
mission
and it was horrible work
now in how many of you are sat there
going yeah but would you really write
Pearl because like D3 is a thing and any
of you like sat there going I know
better
I just want to remind you of a timeline
V bulletin launched in 2000. Facebook
which is where a lot of communities and
ended up and then tour and all of those
weird places came much later Facebook
first launched in 2004 but it was closed
it was only for University students at
that point the Facebook we know and love
didn't really start getting Popular
until say 2010 2011. so we had this
period between 2000 2010 where these
forums were still very very much the
popular place for a community to hang
out
the tooling you would have chosen to
write this in
literally wasn't launched yet D3 the
nice thing that you'd use to graph out
some really simple things in JavaScript
we've all done it at some point or other
it wasn't launched until 2011.
so whenever we had to do a visualization
whenever we had to map out connections
between data we had to build it
ourselves and I'm not that Survivor
person who says yeah you had to do it
yourself and that made me cool
it didn't it made me really tired
but from a security point of view I knew
what I'd written
at this point in time I start getting
active in a wasp and I was part of what
was called the esapy project for PHP now
that was a library that existed because
PHP at the time didn't have any security
built in and before you all go yeah but
LOL PHP
looking at you all the other languages
that got there just as late
every language had one of these PHP one
of these esapy Frameworks and it was a
bolt-on designed to give you security
controls where there were none in your
framework
at that point in time there was nothing
that we could do that was simple so we
knew explicitly where we had to put the
security because we had to do it line by
line if it didn't exist we had to write
the library to do it for us
I love this this is not mine um but and
it doesn't came it goes only up to
2015-ish
um but I don't know where you are on
this but if you map out your journey in
the languages you've seen and used
you start to really realize how we take
for granted in the libraries and
Frameworks what we're using now and how
many of them are actually really recent
things
now that's really relevant for security
because some of the stuff we're building
now
while it is being built at this future
end where we've got all these cool toys
to play with we're building technology
that wasn't imagined when these
libraries and Frameworks were created
so a lot of what we're doing in iot with
this commoditized products what we're
doing in natural language processing
while we're at this end of the timeline
it doesn't mean we're at the end of the
maturity we don't have the 15 years that
some of our languages have had to mature
their Frameworks and their standards
so what's the solution now to mapping
out data well I want to show you a
library actually that you can go and do
if any of you do any python this is
quite good fun there are many Frameworks
that could help you analyze any sort of
connected data and they come mostly from
the security community so if you don't
hang out in that place I don't blame you
um this could be your time to go and
have a look into the threat intelligence
space
but I have to start with a story
so there's a really wonderful security
researcher called Thomas Rocher he is
part of the Microsoft threat
intelligence group and he tells the
story very well do check out his talks
but he does research and his tools have
been developed because of things like
the Conti breach any of you heard of the
Conti ransomware
yeah if you haven't it's the biggest
most effective ransomware of the last
two years it was decimating
organizations globally it was a dual
fronted ransomware attack whereby you
were having to pay to get your data
unlocked but then later on they were
also making you pay for not releasing
your data because you know they had it
too so you know they could then send it
whoever they liked
um it's believed to have been Russian
state-owned and there's a lot of
evidence behind that and it affects all
versions of Windows and was highly
engineered now you think your devops is
good you wait till you see how
ransomware began to operate if you want
to learn who's at The Cutting Edge a
fast-paced software development that's
multi-platform don't look in Dev look in
the aggressive security Community
because they've got their game on
the United States government thought
this was so problematic that they
offered a 10 million dollar reward for
any information relating to this now
that's unprecedented for a government to
offer a reward for that kind of problem
now what happened though in February
this year is the Ukraine conflict
started which um you know I'm not here
to comment on that it's a terrible
terrible event that continues to be a
really horrible situation today
now the Conti group being rush and
backed put out a proclamation they said
that they were supporters of the Russian
attempts on Ukraine and that they would
retaliate against anyone who seemed to
be supporting Ukraine
now much to Conti's discussed an
anonymous member of the Conti group did
not share this Viewpoint and decided to
leak all of their messages and this
message Chat this logs go from the
beginning of 2020 to February 2022 every
message sent from Conti as an
organization to each other and this is
gold if you're in threat intelligence if
your job is to understand a community
identify the power makers identify where
they're doing things and how they're
doing things this is the data set you
want to be playing with
it was 60 000 fragmented check uh chat
messages across platforms like jabber
and Rocket chat like I said about the V
bulletin thing never underestimate what
technologies are still being used out
there online to get the job done in
certain circles
now if I'd have done this by hand back
in the day this would have been very
very painful fragmented data is like
that so let me show you what Microsoft
did Microsoft did a good thing I'm not
I'm not a Microsoft employee never have
been but I've got a respectment for this
in 2019 before this happened they open
sourced something called Mystic which is
a python framework for threat
intelligence and security and what it
does is it turns large sets of data that
you might see in an attack like URLs and
people and payloads and all these kind
of things it has this idea that you'd
want to collect all the information
about it and map it all together to tell
the story so that you can investigate
so it's been released open's awesome
free you can go and get it today and
whereas back in the day we would have
had to really very manually map this
data
it's very simple these are four examples
from their docs of how to create a
social network from data you just simply
say hey I have an object of X-Type you
add that object there's an incident or
an alert or a person or a URL and then
you say
entity graph
it's like some magic word it's cool
now for somebody who wants to just get
the job done this is amazing and it
gives you this graph now it doesn't just
give you that graph though it gives you
this graph
this is a map of the Conti Network this
is all the people inside Conti the
organization and what they were able to
do was not just track down you know oh
there were 20 people and they were kind
of nice they could identify who was
actually who to the point where oh that
person over there is actually also that
person over there haha fun now what can
you do with that data
you can stop bad things from happening
now not all of you work in spaces where
you try and stop bad things happening
for a living that's cool that's a good
life choice it's hard work
but in your world being able to identify
data that is actually the same as each
other in some way and deconflict that is
really cool
the future of technology is looking a
lot like components we can pull together
to do amazing things without the hard
work
and that's not a bad thing but it
changes the way we do security
it changes it because the guidelines we
have today the way that we do software
the OAS top 10 and I love OAS please
don't take this the wrong way
those guidelines were not built with the
future in mind I want to show you
something this is the OAS top 10 in 2003
and in 2021 so this is the oldest and
newest version of the OS top 10. now who
wants to play Spot the Difference
yeah if you have a look there even if
they're called slightly different things
at least 60 of the OAS top 10 has not
changed in 15 years but when I look at
what you've done in the last 15 years
and what I've done in software in the
last 15 years I've gone from writing 30
000 lines of java to writing six lines
in a framework I found on the internet
are these guidelines really going to
help us in a world where we aren't
controlling all of the processes of
processing of information anymore
that we're trusting other components to
do it for us
this makes it really hard
at guidelines now protect us from what
has previously been not what is coming
next they're like your employee handbook
at work or the reason we have beware
there's nuts on a peanut packet it's the
scar tissue of a previous mistake
and it's not a bad thing but we need to
anticipate the mistakes we myself
included are going to make in the future
and we need some guidance right now
about how we're going to adapt to this
because the iOS top 10 is not going to
help us if we are using these commodity
components if we are using things that
are built from other people's code
now you could argue that while the other
people are responsible for the security
right they they provided the library
they should do it
but who's going to hold them to that is
it going to be the voluntary standard
from the US government is it going to be
you are you going to be like due
diligence person with your spreadsheet
hey hey open source project I need you
to have met this checklist
it's not going to work so we have to do
something else
we have to have security guidance that
copes with problems we aren't seeing yet
so increased architectural complexity
distributed systems are no longer
theoretical they are mainstream if you
are not split into microservices you're
probably over multiple different clouds
in some way or another and you're using
third-party components in the form of
libraries and Frameworks as well as
third-party SAS Solutions many of which
are currently being advertised you in
the lovely Expo area today
all of us are connected
we have a larger development community
there are 30 million software developers
in the world today 30 million and it
grows at a rate of six percent that's
1.2 million per year now if we could all
fit all of us in the dev community in
one room and say hey team can we all
agree we need to do security let's do it
now can we all agree we need to do
security raise your hand please if you
don't raise your hand you're staying
until you do good
um easy great I can see all of you I
know where you work it's on your
t-shirts
um we'll sort it all out but 30 million
people how are you even going to do that
you cannot imagine how much software
that is it's incomprehensible
our software no longer has linear code
Pathways so when we've done our testing
and our intelligence before we would
look at it and go okay so if I do this
here the output will be this over here
but with many of our emergent Behavior
systems that's not how they work there
is a dynamic ever-changing model of what
the outcome would be based on the data
that's going in
that makes it really hard for us to do
some form of static analysis or threat
analysis on that system
there's increased regulation now we're
in Australia I'm not here to bag on
Optus hug offs to the Optus team you've
had a really bad two weeks
but
regulation is coming as a result
it will absolutely come and it will
change things that will impact all of us
whether you deal with Telco data or
whether you deal with Optus or another
Telco it will Ripple through our whole
community
we have new categories of problems to
solve predefined corpuses of data now if
any of you remember the whole Microsoft
made a chatbot and it became a Nazi
Fiasco that's going to happen again
because whenever you put data in if that
data is bad bad things will come out the
other end and who looks at the data well
nobody because there's a huge sense of
data so how do we do that
how do we look at pre-trained models and
decide they're okay and safe how do we
look at large complex data sets without
exposing individuals to harm because
we've got too much data and we don't
know how to protect it
how do we deal with mass-produced
commodity Technologies and libraries and
Frameworks without slowing down so much
that we get in the way of it being mass
and commodity and fun
like my world is hard right now your
world is hard right now I want you to
build a crazy sci-fi future and I also
want you to take very good care while
you're doing it
yeah great what could possibly go wrong
so for
13 million developers then what can we
do let's stop talking about that firstly
we need to Omit a few harsh home truths
only two percent of organizations right
now according to multiple Global surveys
are actually doing any application
security raise your hand if your your
organization is not Vera code and you do
a lot of appsec I know there's at least
one varico person in the room so
are you doing any upset folks oh good on
you you few I love you keep doing it
keep fight the fight the rest of you
what
the rest of us a lot of us fit into this
fragmented exploration we're giving it a
shot we know there's a thing we probably
need to do but where do you even begin
are you going to say I've got to protect
my code against a threat that I cannot
see taste smell or hear that may or may
not exist in Russia don't know
um that there's a law that may or may
not understand that threat and by the
way I've got 37 hours in my week and my
Sprint is full already
great it's going to go super well many
of us are in this emerging space we're
not doing anything yet and today
hopefully if I can do anything in this
I'm going to get that to change just a
little bit
so what are we going to do to secure the
future what is our option
well firstly we need to understand that
you and the code you write do not do so
in isolation the future of security is
not about one system and one piece of
code it's about the community that we
live in and that we build into
each and every one of you builds
something different whether it's things
you do for fun and for hobbies or
whether it's things you do
professionally whether you're actively
code right now anymore or you've moved
on and you're managing other people who
write code
each one of these items in our ecosystem
has risk with it
the libraries and components we build
from
the applications we build out of those
the architectures we turn those into
the companies and organizations we build
those from and then the relationships
between those organizations
so I run a very small company with 21
people
we don't have a lot of software just a
few projects because we don't need to
build much more than that
but we have over 200 dependencies
we have at least six Cloud suppliers
that are directly connected in to our
stack
things like authentication providers
we have another 102 vendors that we
share data with for various reasons from
you know doing our accounts each month
to ordering cupcakes when it's someone's
birthday
now if you think about attack being
around the motivation and what you want
to do as a bad person it's not about hey
I love SQL injection let's go do that
it's about Hey I Love Money how do I get
that or hey I have a political problem
with people in Czech shirts so hey
gentlemen in the texture over there
we're going to have a bit of trouble
that's what it's we're trying to protect
against we're trying to protect against
motivation
and it's not that they're going to go
and say hey I really like that you've
got sophisticated.net application I'm
going to totally come after that they're
going to take the easiest Pathway to get
to what they want now if that pathway is
going after your application so be it
but if that application is actually
really secure they might go after
another week looking in that chain and
in my chain that's 200 libraries
multiple SAS providers 102 suppliers
there's 21 people on my team you start
to see how many things you need to
protect and understand the risk of
we call this transitive risk the risk
you inherit from others and nobody's
immune from it in fact covid taught us
about transitive risk in a way that
we've never really looked at as humans
alive today
transitive risk of being made Sick by
somebody who happens to be in the same
place as you it's the same risk that we
have of inheriting security
vulnerability from a technology or a
component or a system or a company that
we work with
so what we have to do is understand this
risk and how it impacts on us if that's
how we are going to secure the future
it's what it's going to need
this picture is from amvanka it's a
visualization of some of the packages in
the node ecosystem this is not a
Rickroll you can go there and you can go
play around with it but for me it's a
really physical visceral reminder of how
connected we are
that one package that I BR I mapped
there links to 358 other packages and
that in turn will link to an exponential
number of projects and packages whether
you're a node shop or not I bet somehow
you're connected to that package just
there
and that means we have to figure out as
a community how we protect all of us
because what we're seeing now is more
supply chain attacks a supply chain
attack is a very fancy way of saying hey
so I'm quite efficient as an attacker
I'm not really interested in attacking
each of you individually to be honest I
don't care that much but if I can get
all of you cool so it's much easier to
attack a component that you all use than
it is to go after each of you
individually now hug UPS again to the
heroko folks I'm certainly not here to
bag on anyone's security but I'm using
them because this happened recently this
was April this year
if you want to see a supply chain attack
in action and look at what happened
there Heroku had a compromise now Heroku
is hosting 13 million applications for
9500 paying customers and a lot of free
users how many of you use Heroku for
even a pet project of yours yeah it's
easy it's free you go roll stuff up it's
fantastic
but somebody compromised it and was able
to get the keys to environments
now you could be like that's fine nobody
uses it for anything sensitive but even
just looking on their website these are
three of their headline customers and
what they use Heroku for so go to a
meeting for video chats thankfully
nobody ever works from home and we never
use video chat so minor risk low
accepted
uh domain names DNS is never the problem
in any issue DNS has absolutely no
critical role to play in any part of our
security infrastructure so we're fine
job two low priority low risk accepted
think MD online patient management
system for doctors fantastic none of you
ever get sick right
no sickness is very rare in this day and
age covid was all a myth
no no it really wasn't this is three out
of 13 million applications so why would
you attack think MD when you can go
after Heroku how many of you use azure
how many of you use AWS don't be ashamed
I know this is.net folk in the room
anyone using Google Cloud
oh
um
so sorry that was that was a cheap shot
and it was not warranted
um
why would you attack individuals when
you can go after shared components maybe
you wouldn't go after Azure maybe you
wouldn't go after Google Cloud platform
because that's like attacking the entire
country but maybe you'd go after a
library that everyone uses or a smaller
SAS provider that's really just growing
and starting out and getting that
traction and that's terrifying we don't
want those younger companies so share
components to be vulnerable we've got to
figure out how to protect us to protect
ourselves we have to protect all of us
and that's really really hard
so what do I want you to do I want you
to go back to your organizations or
whatever you do in the software world
and I want you to take a real look not
at the code you write
but the code you use to write the future
all of those libraries those Frameworks
are SAS products whether it's a hobby
project or a professional one and I want
you to understand the scope of the
ecosystem that touches your world and
think about how you might be able to
think about some of the challenges I've
discussed today things like
pre-made libraries and corpuses
non-linear pathways through code and how
you can start to rationalize and
understand that for yourself
because when one of us is breached if
that one of us is in the right place all
of us are at risk
and that's a problem the future of
security isn't about SQL injection and
that one line of code you're super proud
of
the future of security and the future of
software Security in particular is
trying to figure out a way to get 30
million people to act as one
to stand up against some of the biggest
automated well devops pipelines of
attack you can possibly imagine
you need to understand your
architectural complexity secure your
third-party Integrations turn on to fa
seriously is like 2022.
include the entire Community we need to
maintain availability at all times
It's Tricky and I want you to pick one
of these and just run with it because if
you just take one of them you're further
ahead than most of us are do you
remember only two percent of us are
actually doing this and none of us in
this room
the future of secure development doesn't
belong to people like me I'm on a
mission right now A really very loud and
annoying Mission my mission is to make
myself redundant because this future of
software security doesn't belong to a
nerd who became a penetration tester and
happened to do some OAS stuff
the future of security belongs to the
people who write the code because you
understand it you know where that data
is coming from you know where it ends up
you know what happens to it on the way
and you know what you chose to build
that software out of
you are the future of securing software
and I need every single one of you to
start and have nothing to offer you
really some stickers and a pin badge
but it's part of quality it's part of
saying my software is performant and
scalable and usable and accessible and
all of those things we want to do I want
you to add one more to that list and say
to write good quality software is to
write secure software and that is not
optional anymore
now I'm going to put my money where my
mouth is and this is not a sales pitch
you can stay on this free version
forever I do not care I'm not here to
hunt you down that QR code there will
get you and your team essential secure
development training free of charge
anywhere in the world and you can do
that right now I have no qualms with you
doing it
yes if you're bigger you can totally buy
things it's a company but we won't
hassle you because we've put a line in
the ground and we've said enough is
enough
the future of security isn't buying
something it's not a tool you buy from a
vendor stand it is not something that
will solve your problems it is not like
buying a treadmill and hoping it makes
you fit the future of security is
changing the way you think and making
yourself and everyone in your team part
of the security team and doing one
little tiny thing every day to build
that secure future as you build a
technology that is some of the most
exciting the world has ever seen
so that's a bit preachy for a keynote I
admit it it's nine o'clock in the
morning you've done very very well
but I would encourage you to get
involved there and if it's not that find
something else go download oh wash
g-shop go look out into the world and
find your way to join the team of 30
million software developers so that I
can step back and you can show me how
amazing the future of technology is
going to be and how it's going to be
secure from day one
thank you so much
if not you will find me loitering around
um yeah that's what I do at conferences
um I have stickers and pin badges I like
to talk about security
um and I'm an introvert playing very
hard at being an extrovert so don't be
shy
so lovely to meet you all thank you so
much and enjoy your conference
[Applause]